President Trump has now wrapped up the
first day of an important state visit to
China he wants China's President to help
crackdown on North Korea's nuclear
weapons program by cutting down on trade
they're nearly all of China's trade with
the Hermit Kingdom flows through the
Chinese city of Dandong
North Korea is just half a mile away
across a river Ben Tracy went to den
dong to see if China is making good on
promises to follow recent UN sanctions
he is in Beijing now and good morning
good morning without China North Korea
would likely collapse that's because
China accounts for about 90 percent of
trade with Kim Jong Un's isolated regime
and some of the money that China has
spent on things like North Korean
clothing North Korean coal has likely
helped pay for that country's weapons
program but now there is evidence that
China is becoming a less generous
neighborhood this is what trade between
China and North Korea
looks like trucks loaded with Goods
passing over this single lane bridge
spanning the Yalu River Chinese tourists
flock here to Dan dong to get a glimpse
of their notorious neighbor so we can't
shoot on this street
journalists are less welcomed ten
minutes after we arrived on a street
lined with North Korean businesses we
were stopped by Chinese police they want
to take you to the police station the
police deleted our video of goods being
sent to North Korea so we used an iPhone
to shoot this footage from a building
nearby we saw what appeared to be
construction materials and heavy
machinery heading towards the bridge
it's often hard to tell what's being
moved between China and North Korea in
these trucks the Chinese government says
it is strictly enforcing all United
Nations sanctions those now include a
ban on exports of North Korean coal iron
and textiles but in August China
purchased 1.6 million tonnes of North
Korean coal worth nearly 140 million
dollars just days before the sanctions
went into effect overall the Chinese
government claims its trade with North
Korea has dropped significantly
but China still refuses to cut North
Korea off at the knees because it fears
if the regime collapses Rep
geeze from here in North Korea will
stream across the border here into China
and worse yet they will see the US
military just across this river some
Chinese traders may be violating the
sanctions including the ban on North
Korean seafood off-camera this woman at
Dan dongs fish market admitted some of
her fish came from North Korea when we
turned the camera on she said it was all
from China so none of this fish is from
North Korea no she says nobody would
dare sell any this Chinese seafood
trader asked us to conceal his identity
he says his business is down 60% because
of the sanctions to your knowledge is
North Korean seafood still being
imported into China yeah yes definitely
yes he says it's a very long border and
you can't watch everyone how is North
Korean seafood still getting into China
well maybe knees fishermen go over the
border to North Korea he says or meet in
international waters China is helping
ensure that the North Korean regime
survives by significantly boosting its
exports of grain and corn North Korea
faces chronic food shortages and China
is literally its lifeline kale thank you
Ben Tracy reporting from Beijing